So why are field techs so important? Let's take
an example of an email address. Now you could format
that as a plain text field and then users would
enter so and so at something dot something and it
would work in most cases. Now the great part
about choosing a data type is that it provides automatic
data validation. Someone couldn't enter in an illegal email address,
because the, they wouldn't be able to save their record.
Moreover, that functionality of that will later show up in
an app so we will be able to tap that email
address and it would open a mail-to link and their default
email application. That's great functionality, so we want to make sure
to use the data text that users expect for it. If
it's a calendar, choose the date type. If it's email, choose
email, etcetera. Now the best way to learn is by doing
so let's go back with Samantha and Andy and do that.